back in the 90s johnny sullivan was
hurting johnny got into a construction
accident in 1992 that left him in
extreme pain it felt like somebody had
an ice pick all the time gouging right
down in my backbone just wiggling all
the time
and uh it seems like the pain goes right
up to your brain i mean it just
devastates your brain so bad i mean yeah
and uh it's like somebody's standing
there gouging all the time it's 24 hours
a day seven days a week even after
getting surgery he was still in constant
pain and since he couldn't work anymore
his life was falling apart and he was
losing everything his phone his life
insurance he almost even lost his home
but then he found his miracle oxycontin
there is always something that can be
done to reduce pain these magic little
pills made all his pain just melt away
johnny was so happy that he found
oxycontin that he actually ended up
being part of the pills marketing
campaign
telling the world how oxycontin gave him
his life back
i got my life back now now i can enjoy
every day that i live i can really enjoy
myself and before
even a good day was hell i mean i
couldn't enjoy nothing but now i can
enjoy myself that's when i said
wonderful they're marketing it in such a
way telling us that this will be the
best thing that we could ever use for
pain for patients and it's non-addicting
because it's a time release drug and we
don't have to worry about addiction and
this is the best thing you could ever do
and we're really encouraging that he
started enjoying his life again he was
able to work again to support his family
johnny had hope again but it wouldn't
last long because less than 10 years
later johnny would turn up dead he had
become addicted to oxycontin and one day
johnny fell asleep while driving his
truck flipped it and died instantly and
just like that the drug that gave johnny
his life back killed him and johnny
wasn't some junkie or drug addict he was
just a regular guy who didn't want to be
in pain anymore a regular guy who
trusted the drug doctors prescribed them
they've been told by doctors and they've
been told by a large company
that the risk of taking this stuff is
minimal and the potential benefits are
unlimited
the sad part is that this is not an
uncommon story there are millions of
johnnies out there who are convinced
oxycontin would save their life since
i've been on this new pain medication i
have not missed one day of work and my
boss really appreciates that lauren is
there every day only to come find out
that oxycontin was an insanely addictive
drug that led to the death half a
million deaths to be exact out of this
nearly one million americans have died
from drug overdoses in the last two
decades and more than 70 percent of them
involved opioids
a hundred thousand people died from drug
overdose over the 12 months ending in
may 2021
up 22 percent from the year before
medically assisted treatments can be
effective but have a relapse rate of
about 50 percent
this is going to be the worst drug that
we've ever seen come into this county
and it's going to cause us more problems
than any drug we've ever ever seen
before but who was behind this massacre
a quick google search will point to a
company called purdue pharma the
creators of oxycontin which is correct
but if you dig a little deeper you'll
come across the family dynasty that
owned purdue pharma a very powerful
family that's made billions after the
deaths of half a million americans and
practically got away with them a family
that has tried very hard to keep their
name in the shadows a family named the
sackler family i get the impression that
you have a very good time
i'm having a ball
my name is jake tran i make
documentaries on money power war and
crime in my team subscribe for more if
you want to win a thousand dollars cash
you just have to be following me at
jaketren and you're automatically
entered a few of you have won already
watch out for fake accounts i will never
message you asking for money and this is
the story of the sacklers the most evil
family in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
people like the sacklers are always one
step ahead they make sure their entire
family is financially secure no matter
what happens and one of the ways they
protect their empire is by getting
top-notch life insurance now you may
think life insurance is only for the
super wealthy but it's actually the
total opposite we need it way more than
them
most of us are really protective of our
stuff we insure our homes our cars our
electronics because you never know
what's going to happen but for some
reason most of us don't try to protect
our family's finances if you were to die
tomorrow all of your debt wouldn't just
magically go away your mortgage student
loans etc will get passed on to your
loved ones that could be your partner
your parents or maybe even your kids
that is why you need life insurance life
insurance would give your loved ones a
financial cushion against these things
in case you die
the problem is the longer you wait to
get life insurance the more expensive it
gets and finding the right life
insurance policy is really hard but
fortunately that is where policy genius
comes in today's video sponsor policy
genius is an insurance comparison
website that makes it easy to compare
quotes from top companies all in one
place to find you the lowest price
they've already helped over 30 million
people and it's super easy to get
started just head over to
policygenius.com with the link below
answer a few questions about yourself
and boom you could save 50 or more on
life insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius one of their 400 plus
license experts will explain your
options to ensure you're applying for
the right policy and then when you're
ready to apply policy genes will handle
all the paperwork and scheduling for
free the cool thing about policy genius
is that they're not working for
insurance companies they are working for
you they never sell your information to
other companies and there are no extra
hidden fees policy genius is an
insurance marketplace not an insurance
company so they're there to help you
every step of the way just head over to
policygenius.comtran to get your free
life insurance quotes and see how much
you could save that's
policygenius.comtran for your free life
insurance quotes thanks to policy genius
for sponsoring this video
[Music]
so you're the sackler family in the
1980s the owners of the infamous purdue
pharma company up until now you've been
pretty successful in building power
influence and money and by the 1980s
you're one of the richest families in
the country maybe even the world but
that's not enough you're hungry for even
more
luckily for you
by the 1980s the painkiller industry was
gaining a lot of traction as a
pharmaceutical company painkillers were
right up your alley
and lately you'd been having a lot of
success with a hip new painkiller called
ms conten the content in the name stood
for continuous which was exactly how
this new miracle painkiller worked
basically ms content was a morphine pill
with a patented controlled release
function
that allowed the drug to slowly spread
through your body and for the effects to
last a much longer time
it had been done with an antihistamine
before but never something as powerful
or potentially useful as morphine
ms content was put out as a solution for
cancer patients managing debilitating
pain and oh man did it work
the thing that made ms content so
different from other pain killers on the
market was that it was supposed to leave
patients blessed with 12 hours of
continuous pain relief for cancer
patients it was a lifesaver
for years most of them had been
struggling to sleep through the night on
medications that only lasted a measly
five to seven hours now here was a pill
that could last all night
it was a medical breakthrough for the
world and a financial breakthrough for
you and purdue pharma almost instantly
ms content became the biggest seller in
purdue's history generating 170 million
dollars per year in sales it took you
from being just any other rich family to
a mega rich 1 level family and then you
ran into your first problem
your patent on ms content was about to
expire and you had to come up with
something new fast
but instead of looking at this switch up
as a burden you saw it as an opportunity
an opportunity to solve ms content's
biggest problem it's customer base
yeah sure lots of people had cancer but
just putting ms content in a box and
making it the cancer drug limited all
its other possibilities it was a
horrible business tactic plus soon other
companies were going to start catching
on and ms content would have some
generic competition you hated that
but
what if instead of just selling pills to
the thousands of people with cancer you
could sell them to the millions of
americans with more common everyday
ailments
the americans with back pain or
menstrual cramps or sports injuries what
if instead of just prescribing them to
people that are going to die soon you
could get doctors to prescribe them to
people that would be buying monthly for
the next 20 to 40 years
now that could make you really really
rich
you see ms cotton was basically just
morphine repackaged under a new brand
and everyone already associated morphine
with dying when someone was being
administered morphine it meant that they
were knocking on death's door and needed
a super strong drug to numb the pain and
that wasn't really how you wanted your
customers to perceive your new miracle
drug you needed something fresh
something that the public and doctors
didn't already have preconceived notions
about something that they didn't know
much of anything about
enter oxycodone
you see this powerful opioid painkiller
had been created by another pharma
company way back in 1916
the only problem was oxycodone's effects
only lasted four to six hours so every
couple of hours or so the pain would
come back and people would have to pop
another pill
not only was this inconvenient but it
also meant getting addicted to the drug
was way easier doctors had to give
patients so many oxycodone pills to
manage their pain during the day that
using too many at once or using them too
often quickly left people addicted to
its effects
but a pill made of pure oxycodone with a
time release formula like ms conten that
would change the game
not only was it cheap and easy to make
but best of all it was super strong
like stronger than morphine
so it would take away all the stigma of
morphine while still administering the
same or an even stronger effect the
public would eat it right up
and they did
that's how purdue eventually ended up
releasing their most prized product
oxycontin
the drug that would make you enough
money to buy a wing with the sackler
name in nearly every museum university
and public building in the country the
drug that would spark the opioid
epidemic in the united states turning
five percent of the u.s adult population
into addicts and killing over half a
million americans in the process
with alcohol it was a new flavor it was
kind of it was typical
are you telling me in a single year 2015
more americans died of heroin or opioid
overdoses than died in the 9 11 attacks
and hurricane katrina combined a
colorado mother sharing her grief
tonight her son died after she says his
doctor over prescribed him medicine
[Music]
even though the sackler family is the
31st richest family in america today it
wasn't always that way before purdue
before the wealth before the infamy
the sacklers were just three brothers
from brooklyn
arthur mortimer and raymond their
parents had immigrated to the united
states from poland and galicia now part
of modern day ukraine in new york the
family made a pretty nice living owning
a grocery store but that wasn't good
enough for their oldest son arthur
he was born to be a leader and had that
insatiable drive for success that most
entrepreneurs could only dream of but
arthur was also very egotistical
as a kid he started working at his dad's
grocery store he went to high school
when he was just 12 years old and by the
time he was 15 he had enough money from
his variety of side hustles to help
support his family
soon he was working more jobs than he
could possibly handle by himself so he
started passing off the opportunities to
his little brother morty then his
youngest brother ray got sent to work
too arthur got them both positions
selling ads for their school's student
magazine the dutchman they even managed
to land an ad for chesterfield
cigarettes targeted at students
the ad earned them all a nice fat
commission
their first taste a fortune
but while arthur and his brothers were
raking in the cash their parents
business took a turn for the worse
with no money for university it looked
like arthur's dreams of making it big
were unattainable
but arthur was determined to make it
determined to prove himself to the world
in the end arthur and his brothers would
end up surpassing even his wildest
dreams
[Applause]
[Music]
arthur graduated from high school and
joined new york university in 1929
right when the stock market crashed and
the great depression began
even though he had no money left and
most of his books were used and falling
apart arthur loved college when he
wasn't studying he was working on the
college newspaper or waiting tables in
the student cafe on campus he would send
money back to his parents and mentored
his brothers on how to do well at their
jobs while he was away by the time
arthur graduated from college he had
enough money from all these odd jobs to
buy a new store for his parents
and all of this was during the great
depression when the unemployment rate in
america hit 25 percent and people were
losing their homes and businesses faster
than ever before
even at such a young age arthur sackler
had proven his money-making abilities
and then he went off to start medical
school inspired by medicine arthur used
to say a physician can do anything and
he took that very literally
after graduating with his medical degree
and interning at a hospital for a few
years he started working at creedmoor
psychiatric center in 1944
he'd become fascinated by psychiatry
even though it wasn't a highly regarded
field of medicine at the time
at creedmoor he worked in a special ward
for violent women
his job administering electroshock
treatments
far from its watered-down form today in
the 1940s electroshock treatment was a
brutal way doctors tried to rewire the
brains of mentally ill patients
impressed by his success arthur's
younger brothers followed in his
footsteps
they studied medicine at the same school
and it wasn't long before mortimer and
raymond were also working at creedmoor
and shocking the patients in their time
at the psychiatric center the brothers
administered thousands of electroshock
procedures and they hated it
they thought it was pitiful that the
incredible world of american medicine
hadn't figured out the human mind beyond
shocking it into compliance
so they started doing some experiments
on why electroshock treatments were
making people more docile
they realized that the procedure was
creating a chemical reaction in the
brain that produced a relaxed calm
effect
so what if they could cut out the middle
man of shocking people or sticking ice
picks in their brain and just inject
patients with a substance that makes the
brain release these chemicals
that's how the sackler brothers started
focusing on chemical solutions to the
mental illness problem
since arthur had a unique background in
editing and publishing for school
newspapers he started running articles
educating the public about their line of
thinking the philadelphia inquirer even
printed a story on how quote doctors
think they have found a means of
treating mental ailments without
hospitalization end quote
the sacklers were well on their way to
making drugs for mental illness the next
big thing
luckily they'd hit marketing gold with
their timing
penicillin had just come out and
everyone was on board for the miracle
drug era at first arthur started working
as the marketing genius for other
pharmaceutical companies the biggest
cash cow of the lot being pfizer this is
where he really developed his trade of
naive advertising going for consumers
who didn't know they're being advertised
to camouflaging paid promotions as
editorials or research papers
it's still a popular trick in the
advertising world today but back then it
had never been used in the medical world
and it would change
everything
by 1952 the brothers had accumulated
enough money to go in together on a
joint venture nothing too crazy
just a little investment for a small
patent medicine company
called purdue frederick
they bought the company for fifty
thousand dollars when they first bought
purdue it was a fixer-upper the company
had a few boring everyday products like
an earwax remover and a laxative but
nothing that was going to bring the
wealth and esteem that the sacklers
craved
so they moved towards more exciting
markets
first they got into marketing cat
tranquilizers but not long after they
realized that there was a way bigger
market to take advantage of a market
they had first been introduced to back
at the creedmoor psychiatric center that
market was anxious humans
so purdue frederick started pushing two
drugs called librium and valium as the
cures for anxiety and stress
but that wasn't enough
soon they were recommending it for
recovering alcoholics and muscle spasms
that's when arthur and his brothers
started getting really really rich
that's when they realized that if they
took one of their magic pills and
marketed it to everybody for everything
they were going to make millions and
millions of dollars
and they did
with all their valium money the brothers
became public philanthropists of
everything from the arts to education
they donated entire libraries to ivy
league universities and wings to some of
the most well-respected museums in the
world each proudly bearing the sackler
name
by the 80s the sacklers were richer than
any of us could probably imagine
everyone was telling arthur to sit back
and enjoy the spoils of his hard work
that he could finally relax
but arthur sackler was far from relaxed
and that finally caught up with him in
1987
when he suddenly died from a heart
attack
at the age of 73 the patriarch of the
sackler family was dead
people expected his empire to fall apart
but little did they know it was only the
beginning of the sackler family's money
hungry dynasty
[Music]
arthur had created a whole new world
around his advertising narrative he
combined flashy advertising with using
expert medical opinions so that no one
could really tell the difference and
people would just trust whatever the
company sold
his ad campaigns were perfect at
convincing consumers to believe half
truths or exaggerations as if they were
facts and he passed on that knowledge to
his family by the time he died the next
generation of sacklers were already
getting involved in the family business
like raymond's son richard who ended up
being a huge driving force behind the
success of oxycontin
but even with all the new people joining
the company arthur's medical marketing
genius wasn't forgotten
quite the opposite in fact
when they stumbled across the idea of
developing and marketing oxycontin as
the cure-all for anything from back pain
to cancer the sackler family once again
called on arthur's tried and tested
marketing techniques to skyrocket sales
higher than ever before
here's how it worked
step one
find a substance that people aren't
scared of but that will still be
effective at curing their every little
ache and pain
like oxycodone yeah sure it's super
addictive but that doesn't matter
just find a way to market it as totally
safe like a new fancy time release
formula that makes it impossible to ever
get addicted step 2
create a wide range of pill doses pump
out the little 10 milligram ones for the
newbies and massive jumbo doses up to
160 milligrams for the veterans that way
when the patients get used to the effect
of the smaller doses and they will
there's always another oxycontin pill
for them to buy from their doctor
step three target your ads toward the
people with all the power the doctors
use arthur's old tactics of naive
advertising to convince america's
doctors that oxycontin is a gift from
god that it's the miracle drug they've
needed to cure their patients every
ailment that they should be prescribing
oxycontin
for everything
that it's a magical long-term solution
to pain
publish medical journals about how
incredible oxycontin is
hire medical salespeople to go hospital
to hospital spreading the good word
about it
pay for doctors to go on all expenses
paid seminars about oxycontin at
luxurious locations give away a month's
worth of free samples to anyone that
will take it
step 4 sit back and watch the billions
flow in
thanks to its addictive properties it
won't be long until it's basically
impossible to find a person on the
street who isn't on oxycontin
and that's exactly what you the sackler
family did when oxycontin was approved
by the fda in 1995 to treat moderate to
severe pain
you marketed it to treat everything
soon u.s sales of oxycontin exceeded
those of viagra even though purdue
hadn't conducted any clinical studies on
just how addictive the drug was
you didn't care that doctors weren't
just prescribing a drug as dangerous as
oxycodone for short-term pain relief
you wanted it to be marketed to people
who were managing lifelong
they were your forever customers
and it didn't stop there oxycontin
salespeople were meticulously trained on
how to sell doctors and hospitals on the
pill if the customers dared to raise
objections about the potential for
addiction the salespeople were told to
repeat this phrase exactly
quote the delivery system is believed to
reduce the abuse liability of the drug
end quote
it was vague and a little meaningless
but it was also a lie
purdue knew it the sacklers knew it
everyone knew but they didn't care
because there was just too much money on
the line
and their greed and selfishness would go
on to cost thousands of lives
[Music]
after releasing oxycontin their miracle
drug the sacklers had officially
developed a financial empire but the
reality of oxycontin started taking its
toll almost immediately right after it
was released people started abusing it
it started in maine and appalachia
people realized that it was pretty easy
to bypass the time release formula by
grinding up the pills and snorting them
or dissolving them in liquid and
injecting them just like the oxycodone
in the early 1900s using oxycontin in
this way would provide a huge hit of
oxycodone all at once and the more
popular oxycontin got with doctors the
bigger the black market for it became on
the streets
but it wasn't just drug dealers or
stereotypical addicts misusing the
miracle of oxycontin it was everyday
regular people
these people would go to the doctor for
a pain problem be prescribed oxycontin
and end up with a lifelong addiction and
most of these people had no idea what
they were getting into they were just
doing exactly what they were told and
trusting their doctor
and not even the doctors prescribing
oxycontin knew how deep purdue's lies
ran
remember the whole reason the pill was
so revolutionary the innovative
never-before-seen time release formula
that was supposed to make the pain
relief last 12 hours it was the most
crucial part of their marketing strategy
but purdue wasn't even sure any of it
was true
according to purdue's own internal
documents the company was aware that not
all patients who took oxycontin were
achieving 12-hour relief
in fact most of them were not
but that didn't stop them from pushing
doctors to prescribe an addictive
substance to people in pain telling them
it would work for 12 hours while knowing
it would probably only work for seven
and when that happens what do the
patients do
they take another pill
that's how you take someone who was
never an addict and get them hooked for
life or worse
dead
like jill skolek in 2002 jill was 29
years old and lived in new jersey she
was a stay-at-home mom with a
six-year-old son
after a back injury jill went to her
doctor who prescribed oxycontin
after only four months on the drug she
had a respiratory arrest in her sleep
and died
she hadn't been addicted to oxycontin
but purdue had left out most of its
safety risks when marketing it to her
doctor and that had led to her death
her mother went on to dedicate her life
to telling the world about how dangerous
oxycontin is
or joe scarpone a retired marine who was
prescribed oxycontin and later died of
an opioid overdose or one of the
thousands of babies that are now born
every 30 minutes with a physical
dependency on opioids because their
mother was addicted
or any of the other half a million
people who have died from opioid
overdoses since the epidemic began
in 2017 the united states declared the
opioid crisis a public health emergency
and even though the sacklers thought
they could hide in the shadows forever
never taking accountability for purdue
or what they did they've finally been
exposed for who they really are
[Music]
[Music]
in 2020 the sackler family's lies caught
up with them
after months at court purdue pharma
pleaded guilty to fraud and paying
kickbacks to promote their products
the court found that purdue pharma the
sackler family and their aggressive
marketing techniques used to shift
public perception of oxycontin were key
in developing the opioid epidemic that
they played a vital role in half a
million people dying epidemic on
all fronts and for their crimes the
sackler family has to pay a six billion
dollar settlement and surrender control
of purdue and that number could even
increase to as much as 10 billion over
time
now the money and the former purdue
pharma company now renamed noaa pharma
will be used to fight the opioid crisis
it helped create
in exchange everyone in the sackler
family will be protected from any
lawsuits involving oxycontin or the
opioid epidemic in the future if you had
to put a price tag on killing half a
million people i guess it's six billion
dollars many of the modern day sacklers
maintain that this contribution is
generous that oxycontin really was a
miracle drug that got ruined by a bunch
of junkies
i mean what else are they supposed to do
besides pay up
but there's one thing the sacklers have
yet to offer
an apology
yes they've accepted a settlement and
the fine
yes they've given up control of purdue
but
they still can't seem to hold themselves
accountable or even acknowledge the half
a million people who have died from this
epidemic
and i guess they'll never have to now
because even after paying their 6
billion bill guess what
they'll still be billionaires
[Music]
whereas the sackler family pillaged the
big pharma industry over in the
agriculture industry there's another
ruthless titan monsanto
the company that owns the world's food
supply they created the roundup
pesticides that have been linked to
alzheimer's autism and cancer
they manufactured agent orange which
destroyed generations of vietnamese and
american families and they bully farmers
into complying with their genetically
modified seeds so they can control all
our food supply
but the brutality of monsanto goes so
much deeper than that
the thing is videos like this are a
little too controversial to release
publicly so instead we decided to
release a private full-length
documentary all about exposing monsanto
and guys the channel members have been
all over this documentary all you have
to do to see our monsanto documentary
right now and all the other docs that
are just too controversial and dark to
post in public is hit the join button
below once you sign up you'll have full
unlimited access to the monsanto
documentary and others like mk ultra the
bin laden papers efforty epstein the
roots of middle eastern terror and so
many more to come
this is all the stuff you should be
learning in school and university but
unlike school you get all of this for
only five dollars a month
the best part is that if you join and
don't think it's worth it within the
first month just email us and we'll
personally refund you the money after
your first month there is no refund
because a few bad apples decided to
abuse this refund policy click that join
button below right now
[Music]
what's up guys hope you guys enjoyed the
video and if you're new here this is one
of the biggest channels on youtube for
documentaries on money power war and
crime so if you enjoyed this one we make
multiple documentaries just like this
one every single week for free so click
that subscribe button below remember you
can always dislike and unsubscribe
whenever you want so you have nothing to
lose and you can follow me on instagram
for a chance to win a thousand dollars
we've already had multiple winners in
the past that we sent money to and you
can follow me at jake tran but that's
gonna wrap it up stay dangerous out
there and i will see you guys in the
next one
you